y es ahora que quiero encontrar la
derivada de que igual al coseno de 5 x 3
y para esto voy a utilizar lo que hemos
venido aprendiendo la derivación
implícita por lo tanto voy a aplicar el
operador derivada tanto del lado
izquierdo como del lado derecho de esta
igualdad y que voy a obtener bueno
primero tengo la derivada con respecto a
x de ye pues es justo lo que queremos la
derivada de ye gon respecto a x es igual
a la derivada con respecto a x del
coseno de 5x menos 3 y para esto voy a
utilizar la regla de la cadena primero
hay que derivar el coseno y la derivada
del coseno pues es el menos seno ponemos
otra vez todo lo que está adentro del
paréntesis igualito no lo hacemos nada
menos seno de 5x menos 3 james eso es la
derivada del coseno de 5x menos 3 bien y
ahora hay que multiplicarlo por la
derivada de lo que se encuentra dentro
del paréntesis es decir por la derivada
de 5x con respecto a x que es 5 menos
tres veces la derivada de ella con
respecto a x que es precisamente lo que
andamos
y fíjense que ya acabamos la derivada de
la parte derecha de esta igualdad por lo
tanto ahora lo que quiero intentar hacer
es despejar a la derivada de ella con
respecto a x y para eso pues la tenemos
aquí y la tenemos también del lado
derecho por lo tanto lo que se me ocurre
hacer primero es ponerla de color
amarillo es decir vamos tras lo que está
de color amarillo y lo segundo que se me
ocurre hacer es
multiplicar el seno de 5 x 3 tanto por
el 5 como por el menos 3 derivada de 10
con respecto a x eso nos va a ayudar a
poder poco a poco ir despejando a las
derivadas de ye con respecto a x por lo
tanto la derivada de ye con respecto a x
es igual y recuerden que lo que vamos a
hacer es distribuir el menos en 95 x
menos 3 que va a multiplicar tanto al 5
como al menos 3 derivada de ye con
respecto a x por lo tanto primero me
queda el menos cinco veces el seno de 5x
menos tres el seno de 5x menos tres
lleve a nhk y colorido me está quedando
esto y después tengo que multiplicar
menos por menos que me va a dar más y
después va a ser tres veces el seno de
5x menos 3 james el seno de 5x menos 3
james y esto a su vez multiplica a la
derivada de ella con respecto a x la
derivada de james con respecto a x y
hasta aquí vamos muy bien ahora tengo
dos cosas de amarillo tengo esto de
amarillo y esto de amarillo
dos expresiones tienen en común la
derivada de 10 con respecto a x por lo
tanto aquí tengo esta que tiene un 1
esta que tiene tres veces el seno de 5x
menos 3 james y lo que voy a hacer es
pasar restando el tres veces seno de 5x
3 entonces voy a quedar 1 menos tres
veces el seno de 5x menos 3
esto que multiplica a la derivada de
ella con respecto a x recuerden que lo
único que hice o lo único que estoy
haciendo es agrupando términos
semejantes y del lado derecho de la
ecuación me queda menos cinco veces el
seno de 5x menos tres bien esto lo pasé
del lado izquierdo y del lado derecho
solamente me queda el menos cinco veces
el seno de 5x menos tres bien
- 5 de magenta y con rojo el seno de 5 x
menos 3 y bueno ahora lo que me falta es
pasar todo lo que está al lado
multiplicando la derivada de ye con
respecto a x lo voy a pasar dividiendo
entonces ahora sí ya puedo decir que la
derivada de ella con respecto a x
despejada es igual a menos 5 seno de 5x
menos 3 james
entre 1 - 3 veces el seno de 5x menos
tres y menos tres veces el seno de 5x
menos 3 james y ya hemos acabado